oof I gotta has gotta be a gangster oh
you're my spider-sense real quick okay
we are tremendously safe now this is the
lab what's going on here what's in here
Alton it's not their work bench oh yeah
there's this is a good spot um all right
this guy right upgrade this that bar
right here and I've got this and the
capacity yes um your range i guess and
reload span you know um oh yes it's
[ __ ] wherever too I can't recover
yeah it looks good yeah let's get okay
what's going on here I min chart to this
meaning no they're flex are pretty cool
except I can't see my face in the
reflection that's okay
yes I just [ __ ] up at all but I guess
yeah can I make anything yet yeah and if
I could take I gotta reload this ya new
generator Yahoo are flies here for
mankind over here anyone anyone until we
figure out what's going yeah what is
this this'll explain everything nothing
useful in a venir but a bunch of medical
mumbo jumbo don't get it looks like the
old is packed up and left in a hurry
that's why that's I maybe not all of
them stay close
oh of course she just runs up where the
noises that's cool I guess that's cool
now you like snacks me here no I can't
Jesus what can I game is this all right
sometimes I had trouble distinguishing
real holiday from I game I gone here I
have yet
okay that's anyone here there are no
bodies that's good right we found out
where they win I they go [ __ ] strange
in here make anything else no.js this is
weird weird see what's going on over
here a lapse [ __ ] out day yet I'd be
so pissed I went all this way is that no
not that's nothing hmm
in here huh holy [ __ ] what is that good
Ally yes okay you like a [ __ ]
surprise attack or something hey hold a
look
am I going backwards now now the goal is
to keep going up i think there's my
stuff are there a [ __ ] it now take a
[ __ ] well clickers don't hide ok well
i'm famous and this guy out there yeah
oh it's when I oh my god this whole time
I finally [ __ ] forgot what that
shaking me does this a potato Oh God
Oh
no here we go clickers he says well
maybe and all that research they turn
into [ __ ] like lion glad sure to
Alfonzo as this it's for pellets of lab
equipment all packed up and ready to go
now big question is what do we do with
all you guys this entertainment batch
needs to be put down you know what I say
they screw that who made a bigger
sacrifice than you right anyone who
serves to run free out there oh my god
oh really good voice actor a mess with
them monkeys you didn't say no no let's
just keep looking
mm-hmm you know I don't [ __ ] with
monkeys that's one thing i do not do
with you'd never want to [ __ ] with a
monkey I guess I'll [ __ ] you up a
[ __ ] make anything yet there we go
yeah go here [ __ ] this thing there oh
well Terry I admit looking for the
fireflies they've all left yeah no [ __ ]
I'm dead will be soon got me some time
to reflect and years that felt like we
were [ __ ] sing was a giant wasted
tough I'm not gonna do this anymore come
on you for the others they've all
returned to st. Mary's Hospital in salt
lake city you'll find him they're still
trying to save the world good luck with
that he's hospital if ever that is I
knew the city is it far I mean close
horseback what the noise fireflies get
down oh oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are these guy don't matter we
know where to go let's get the hell out
of here take him ass [ __ ]
what's your coming swap this [ __ ]
that's a rifle yeah baby okay lass yeah
ouch
ouch come on kill someone oh jesus not
doin too good is that what that [ __ ] I
want this for sure yeah okay here we go
here we go
oh hey Annie yeah I'll take this I can't
disgusting is what it is
why the music care my god
I only said me all right get that match
that [ __ ] hell he's not doing well Jack
hey asmar here
hang out here I can [ __ ] i'm looking
yeah
I like when she says oh man I'll try I
mean square i'm squaring it yeah it's a
square off Jesus Jesus ok ok ok things
out loud get for him I guess ok get the
guns get the guns oh man oh yeah I could
take out hey you ready 100 dad shut get
to the damn horse ok how's the anyone
let's go this guy ain't gonna make it
that like infinite ammo don't
oh yeah I got a might get better yeah
[ __ ] it fall over here we go san miguel
just stay here those were my friend you
kill us all come on out you want to do
that hard oh my god I way gotta I gotta
we gotta get you outta here I'm okay
you're not ok Jule come on a spatula I
got a man looks like me when I gotta
[ __ ] can I just hit the fellows walk
like that I'll like go on without a shot
a shot here lean on me know
well can you walk yes then [ __ ] walk
this [ __ ] can walk where are the animes
come on
and it's more planet hella
door behind you okay about me Sarge ol
put them to sleep Senor we have a battle
okay a little faster guy I get you out
of this i'm just all singing for me we
don't like him laughs okay chumps all
right yeah I'll bet huh
you too sweet but what is it that
they're just heal that's fetching gonna
can there's no way how's he gonna get
hard yes uh-huh all right
I think we're safe oh don't [ __ ] yo
Oh ditch out for Harambee